زلزال تركيا وسوريا طرح اسئله حول ما يمكن
حدوثه اذا ضرب زلزال مشابه اسطنبول
العاصمه الاقتصاديه لتركيا التداعيات
المباشره لا يمكن تخيلها في اكبر مدن
تركيا وفي اكثرها اكتظاظا بالسكان والتي
تمثل خمسين في المئه من الاقتصاد التركي
بحسب باحثين فالمنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه من
اوروبا الى الشرق الاوسط عرضه للزلازل
فيما المنطقه المحيطه باسطنبول جزء من صدع
شمال الاناضول النشط واي زلزال يمكن ان
يتسبب باضرار كبيره جدا
التوقعات تشير الى ان اسطنبول قد تتعرض
لزلزال بقوه سبع درجات او اكثر خلال
الاعوام المقبله وان تتجاوز خسائر هذا
الزلزال
زلزال السادس من فبراير الاخيره بعد هذا
الزلزال تحدثنا كثيرا عن قوانين البناء او
ما يسمى بكود البناء في تركيا لمقاومه
الزلازل فماذا عن اسطنبول في حال حدوث
زلزال فيها المشكله في اسطنبول تكمله في
ان السبعين في المئه من مبانيها بنيت قبل
عام الفين اي عندما لم تكن هناك عمليات
تفتيش للتحقق من مقاومتها للزلازل
لنفصل بعض الارقام اكثر
اكثر من 250 الفا من مباني اسطنبول شيد
قبل عام
1980 اكثر من ضعف هذا الرقم هو لمبان
اقيمت بين عامي
1980 والفين الجزء المتبقي وهو
376 الف مبنى تاسس بعد عام 2000 الرقم هذا
والذي يمثل 30% من مباني اسطنبول لا يعني
انها امنه تماما راينا في هذا الزلزال
الاخير عندما سقطت مباني فاخره مشيده
حديثا بفعل الزلزال والتي قيل انها كانت
متوافقه مع لوائح الزلازل اثناء البناء
[موسيقى]
اذا وقع زلزال في اسطنبول تسود الخشيه من
ان ما يزيد عن خمسين الف مبنى سيتضرر مع
احتمال مقتل 200 الف شخص في اسوا
التقديرات لكن هل يمكن نقل السكان الى
مساكن امنه الجواب بحسب وسائل الاعلام
التركيه على الاقل نعم فعدد المنازل
الشاغره كاف لاعاده اسكان الذين يقطنون في
مباني شديده الخطوره الا ان القرار هنا
يعود للسلطات التركيه التي لم تتخذ هذا
القرار حتى الان على الاقل الحكومه انشات
بعد زلزال تسعه وتسعين من القرن الماضي ما
اسمته ضريبه الزلازل لتحسين مقاومه
المباني المشيده في المدن
الاحصاءات تشير الى جمع ما يقارب 38 مليار
دولار من خلال هذه الضريبه الخاصه لجعل
المدن التركيه مقاومه للزلازل المعارضه
التركيه قالت ان الاموال المجموعه لم
تستخدم بشكل صحيح وان حكومات حزب العداله
والتنميه برئاسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
جيرت الاموال لتغطيه نفقات حكوميه اخرى
اشارت المعارضه ايضا الى ان قانون الكوارث
اعطى الحكومه حق المصادره باسم حمايه
السكان من الزلازل لكن تم استخدام هذا
القانون للاستحواذ على اراض سعرها عالا في
اسطنبول مع تصاعد المخاوف اطلق رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو حمله لهدم
المباني القديمه واعاده انشائها لتمكينها
من مواجهه اي زلزال محتمل
بدورها كثفت هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه من التمارين على اساس الاستجابه
لسيناريو يضرب فيه زلزال بقوه سبع درجات
ونصف او اعلى مدينه اسطنبول والتركيز على
الاحياء التي من المتوقع ان تكون الاكثر
تاثرا باي زلزال قادم في اسطنبول